The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
SANAM: --the founding
of Genentech.
Yeah, so a little bit about
these two people, first.
We have Herbert Boyer,
who was born in 1936.
He was a biochemist
from Pennsylvania,
an orchard in
Pennsylvania, and then
worked at the University of
California in San Francisco.
And he's, sort
of, considered one
of the first pioneers in the
field of molecular genetics.
And we also have
Robert Swanson, who
was born 1947 and died in 1999.
He was from Brooklyn,
went to MIT,
and then eventually got
into venture capital.
And he was instrumental
in finding Genentech
and, kind of, developing the
financing structure for that.
So here's a list of some other
players that were involved.
They kind of came in throughout
the process of various towns
that were recruited, both,
nationally and internationally.
Boyer worked with Arthur
Riggs and Keiichi Itakura
from the Beckman
Research Institute,
and the group had become the
first to successfully express
a human gene in bacteria when
they produced somatostatin
in 1977.
And then David Goeddel
and Dennis Kleid, as well,
were brought on later
on, in 1978, I believe.
Yeah, and they went on to
be instrumental figures
in the company as well.
So I'll go into a little bit
about what they accomplished--
just, sort of, the early
history of the company.
They really were
the first, kind of,
kickstarted the American
biotech industry.
And it all started when the
two of them kind of met--
Boyer and Swanson met over
beer and lay down $500
to start this
pharmaceutical company that
would explore
proteins that bacteria
could be engineered to make.
And they first
targeted human insulin
because that was, kind of, a
competitive area at the time.
And there was a lot of
demand for treatments,
but there was a worry
that there wasn't
enough supply of animal insulin
to meet this rising demand.
So they kind of
decided on working
to make synthetic
insulin up to scratch
and be competitive with
what was previously used.
And they targeted
meeting the requirements
of Eli Lilly, who they, kind of,
wanted to get his business to--
they targeted his
requirements, they
could get his
business eventually
and get the company going.
So getting money was
kind of a tough process
throughout the entire time.
They both really staked a lot of
their career on this endeavor.
And Swanson, at the
time, was very young
and went through many
periods of unemployment
as he was trying to get the
money for financing this.
And Boyer continued
his day job teaching.
So eventually-- so they ran
into many obstacles financially,
but they also, at
the time, when they
decided to target humans
insulin in the first place,
that kind of kickstarted a
nationwide race to do this.
And so there was
a group at Harvard
and another group at some--
another university
in California.
I'm blanking on the name.
But, yeah, they were
particularly formidable rivals,
and they had those
other two groups
who were, kind of,
entrenched in academia.
And they had all the resources
that that brought them,
whereas Boyer and Swanson
were relatively resource-poor.
But they had one advantage--
Boyer was working with
synthetic DNA, which
would allow him to get around
regulations that the NIH put
on natural DNA
during this process.
So they faced a lot
of other obstacles,
but they still had
advantages-- other teams still
had advantages of scale
and sales ability.
Swanson's goal was
to make Genentech
a fully integrated
pharmaceutical company,
and they wanted--
the eventual goal
was to be able to produce and
sell a wide range of drugs.
And they believed
that if they were
the first to make
the insulin, that
would give them the lift up in
the industry that they needed.
So Swanson went on a hiring
spree and recruited talent.
We were able to open up
their own lab, eventually.
He was able to get 100k
from various sources
for that initial push.
So eventually, by
August of 1978,
they were able to
make their first 20
nanograms of the insulin.
And they immediately
contacted Eli Lilly,
and Swanson kind of
went against convention
and had this huge televised
press conference, where
he announced that
they had achieved
what they wanted to achieve.
And that kind of did
what he intended,
and put Genentech--
really put it on the map
in the public eye.
And eventually,
Eli Lilly's company
came forward with $10
million for Genentech,
and they were eventually
able to fast-track it
for industrial production.
And in 1980, they
had their IPO, and it
was one of the most spectacular
IPOs seen from this industry.
And they were
eventually able to--
in 1985, they were able
to release a second drug.
And these are some of
the early products of--
thank you.
Yeah, so going on to the types
of qualities of great groups
that we've been talking about.
So I think one of
the main things
was Swanson's leadership.
So the article mentioned that he
had a very down-to-earth style
and was well-connected
with everyone
who was involved, as well
as a great generosity
towards everybody.
And so he was-- he
offered, basically,
everyone, from the top
scientists to the custodians,
a share of the
company at one point.
And he had a really great--
effective recruitment of talent.
He was able to see
where they needed people
and how they could
fill those positions.
Another really important
element is that there
was a real conviction of cause.
So Boyer initially wanted to
get into commercialization
because he felt that
university research
and government-funded
research wouldn't allow
him to see the real benefits--
practical benefits--
of his work.
So it's kind of a really
altruistic goal of his.
And that mission kind of carried
them throughout this process--
that they were
going to be making
something that would better
people's lives, save lives.
Another important
element is that they were
working against a common enemy.
So it wasn't exactly an
enemy, but they were--
there were those other teams
that they were working against,
and that competition
really fueled them.
And going along
with that, they were
kind of like the underdogs
and the young company
that didn't have the resources
and didn't have the funding,
so that really was another
motivating factor as well.
Another one is optimism
and a degree of naivety.
So that kind of came into play
when they first made insulin,
but Eli Lilly said
that they needed--
had put really strict
timeline on them
for developing it for
industrial production.
And most people would have
said that that was impossible,
and that they couldn't
do that in that frame.
But they were none the wiser
and kind of went for it anyways
and it ended up
working out for them.
Another thing is that the
people were not interchangeable.
So like I said
before, they were--
that list of players
that I showed you
were very instrumental in
their very specific expertise
that they brought
to the project.
Also that there was
relative freedom
for a lot of the scientists
involved in Genentech.
So one of the
things that Swanson
did to get people on board,
especially David Goeddel,
he said that they could
still have the freedom
to publish under their
own name, even though they
were contracted to Genentech,
so that was a real incentive
for people to join them.
And lastly, there was a
really casual environment
in the office--
T-shirt attire, and there wasn't
any strict rules or a sense
of top-down management.
So some other dynamics that
I think are important--
this was an interesting
case of a great group
because it came at
a time when there
was kind of a changing
relationship between science,
and business, and academia,
and the commercial sector.
And Boyer's journey
was pretty interesting.
He started out
firmly in academia,
but he chose to
look beyond that.
His words, like I said-- his
words at the initial meeting
with Swanson--
about wanting to see the real
practical benefits of his work
kind of carried the
whole team throughout.
But the flipside of that was
that in the early history
of Genentech, he was a target
for academic scientists, who
dismissed the idea that
corporate science would ever
be able to achieve
the kind of things
that they would be
able to achieve.
And his move to
commercialization
really drew the
animosity of academia
because he was one of the
first of many scientist
at the frontier of
molecular biology, who
sought to capitalize on the
commercial opportunities.
And one of Swanson's, and
Boyer's, to some extent,
strength was their
ability to recognize
the exact moment
in basic research
in molecular biotechnology that
was most beneficial to open it
up to a commercial endeavor.
So they were able to combine
an extensive knowledge
of the science that
they're trying to do
and also the business acumen
needed to move it forward.
And this really set them apart
from other big drug companies
at the time, and, I think,
ultimately contributed
to their great success as well.
So this is a quote about
Swanson, who was really,
kind of, one of
the first figures
who was able to really
bridge that partnership
between science and business.
So in a way, you can
kind of think of him
as like an advocate for
the scientists that he
was representing and the
people at Genentech who
were looking to really
advance in this field that
was quite new.
So I guess one of--
going on to, sort of,
discretion questions,
one of my main questions was--
did the relative newness of
this field and this industry
really help them?
I mean, did that
offer opportunities
to Swanson and Boyer that
maybe more established industry
or field would not have?
Did that allow--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
So I'm going to put
that on hold for just
a second and just throw
a couple of framing points out.
But I think that's
a key question,
and I'll lead up to that, Sanam.
This is the first
biotech, right.
This creates the model.
And as you point
out, this combination
of Boyer and Swanson is a
fascinating combination,
because they are, as you put
it, able to kind of bridge
this divide between
business and science,
and that is the
inherent brilliance
of the biotech model.
And these folks really
figure out how to do it,
and Genentech, to this day,
is an extremely successful
company.
So it has been able to keep on
that innovation pathway, which
means that the culture
that they set up here
has been able to keep
innovation occurring
on a kind of ongoing basis.
And some of the points you
made, Sanam, just to emphasize
some of the points you made--
The fact that Boyer and Swanson
allowed their researchers
to do their own
publishing, right,
that they didn't treat
what they were working on
as a complete trade secret--
that was a huge enabler in
enabling the academic community
to kind of enter
into these biotechs.
In other words, their academic
role was going to be respected.
Their role as researchers
and scientists
who contributed in
general knowledge
was going to respect it here.
And that created a rule
in this biotech that
prevails to this
day, and it very much
influenced that kind of model.
But the ability--
So in the biotech model, and
Swanson and Boyer pioneer this,
they create this
revolving door capability.
So in other words, scientists at
universities now in the United
States that work in life
science areas and related areas
are able to have careers,
whether in the Academy--
they move to a biotech as a
scientist for a period of time.
They can move back
to the Academy,
right, taking their
advances with them.
In other words, they can
move between these sectors,
so there was, in
European science,
an historical
upstairs-downstairs treatment,
right?
The academic
scientists thought they
were in curiosity-driven
basic research
and should have nothing
to do with the, kind of,
ugliness and, kind
of, downstairs
of commercialization
of products.
And that these worlds
ought to be kept separate.
And biotech is the first
really serious attempt
in the Academy in
America to kind of bridge
these worlds effectively.
And they do, brilliantly.
And part of it is,
as you point out,
Swanson is a chemistry
major at MIT.
So he is not afraid of
science, just as you suggested.
He understands what it is.
He has the ability
to be in the room
with these academic
scientists and be in the game.
But he also comes to this
with early venture capital
experience.
So he first goes to work
on Sandhill Road in Silicon
Valley, outside Stanford.
And they're only
interested in doing IT.
They have no idea about
this biotech stuff.
So he has to leave this major
event-- early venture capital
firm that he's with and
essentially starve, eat
hot dogs for months
at a time as he
tries to figure
out how is he going
to work in this biotech area?
And famously, he, as Sanam
suggested-- famously,
he starts cold calling.
He has this idea
that bioengineering
is going to be this
incredibly creative new field.
He's aware of it from
his own training.
So he starts cold
calling scientists
that are working in this
bioengineering field.
He only has to get to the
bees, right, to Boyer.
And then they have this famous
meeting at Churchill's Pub,
where they actually
so much hit it off--
exactly as Sanam described--
Boyer is concerned that if
he just stays in the Academy,
nothing he works on is ever
going to get out, right?
And he wants to
get his stuff out.
He truly believes this.
He is not out to get rich here.
He is really out to get--
to save people and get the
technology out the door.
So there's a statue
in front of Genentech,
to this day, that pictures Boyer
and Swanson sitting at the bar,
each putting the $100
down on the table
as they toast each
other with beers.
That's what you see when you
drive in and see the company
headquarters at Genentech.
And that's symbolic, I think,
of what's happening here.
These folks figure out how to
make a really workable marriage
between business
and science that's
remarkably productive on
both sides of the world.
Boyer is totally ostracized
for doing this, right?
He faces tremendous
recrimination
at UCSF for having gone
this commercial route.
And it's only when they come up
with these stunning successes
that the scientific
community really
has to rethink the kind of
way that it went after him.
So this was not easy for
either of these players,
but it's a really--
it's a fascinating
moment, in a way,
creates a culture
that, to this day,
kind of still dominates
that whole sector.
That's a fair summary.
Now, let's come back
to your great question.
Why don't you just pose it
again, quickly, Sanam, and then
we'll do it.
SANAM: Yeah.
Do you want to say something?
AUDIENCE: Actually, I
had a curiosity question.
I was wondering, well--
You had mentioned the ability
to publish under their own name.
Was there anything
else that might
have spurred the success
of this marriage,
as you put it, between
academia and business?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Well that's
[INAUDIBLE] recruitment tool.
In other words, if you
leave academic research--
university labs-- and come
to work for Genentech,
you don't have to abandon
your academic career.
You can still keep
doing your research work
and building your research
reputation while you're
working at a company.
And that's what that enabled.
So it enabled
academic researchers
to feel that they weren't
leaving the universe that they
had-- that had nurtured them.
They could continue doing
terrific academic work, as well
as practical work in this
kind of company setting.
And that was very reassuring,
and it was a great--
it broke down a whole
divide between the worlds,
because previously, in
pharmaceutical companies,
everything was secret, right?
Everything was
treated as a trade.
So there was no
outside discussion
allowed until patents occurred.
This really changed
that culture.
But Sanam, restate
your question,
because it was a very good one.
Let's go back to it.
SANAM: Yeah, so my
question was, do
you think that the fact that
this field was so new and so--
starting very few
years before that
really helped them or afforded
them certain opportunities
that they might not
have been able to have
in a more established,
entrenched field or industry?
AUDIENCE: I'd say
absolutely-- because there
was no previous infrastructure.
There was no
establishment to fight.
There was just the
scientific challenge
and then trying to
commercialize it.
Of course, I mean,
there were other-- there
were other companies that were
trying to do these things,
but because it wasn't as
established as, I don't know,
coal, or the railroad industry,
or something like that.
I think it certainly
made things a lot easier.
The market was a lot more fluid,
and they had a lot more areas
to expand into.
AUDIENCE: I think not
only that-- sorry--
there is also a lot
more room for error,
especially as they're
getting started initially.
They're able to experiment.
They have more leeway in the
way they can market and present
their product, because there
is no established market.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering if
someone could share, maybe,
what they thought the regulatory
challenges that they didn't
face were?
AUDIENCE: I mean, I think it was
mentioned that they pretty much
used the ability to use
synthetic DNA in order to get
over a lot of regulations.
Also, it's relatively early.
Nowadays it's a lot harder.
I think the price point to
make a drug is over a billion.
Back then, I really
don't know what it was.
So really it was a
great opportunity.
Also their investors
were Kleiner Perkins.
Also one of them was--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: --Swanson
had originally worked for,
and then had to leave, because
they didn't want to do biotech.
But he went back to
them with this advance,
and they gave him some money.
AUDIENCE: And I'm
pretty sure they
were in different spaces
that are difficult.
They would have helped.
But the investors were
adequate in that space.
AUDIENCE: What about Chris?
Do you have any thoughts on
the regulatory challenge?
AUDIENCE: Yes, so definitely
using synthetic, kind of,
molecules in an
approach definitely
helps, because you can surpass
that whole clinical challenge,
which not only is hard to pass,
but also takes a long time.
right?
And especially,
they were mentioning
there was a real time crunch.
A lot of groups were doing this
kind of approach and research
in this field.
They really had to be
the first ones out there
so they could
establish themselves
as the leader and the real
innovators in, kind of,
this new biotech field, so.
I think their
approach was smart.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
I mean, this is a moment where
there's a deep concern that
comes up from the public, but
also in the academic community
itself, about the implications
of this genetic engineering,
right?
I mean that's what
Genentech stands
for-- genetic
engineering, right?
That's what they're all about.
And there's a major effort
to put this whole movement
on pause, right.
And there is an outcry in the
city council in Cambridge,
here--
a wild hearing by
the city council
trying to shut down related
research at Harvard and MIT,
because they're very worried
about the implications
of what's going to
be happening here.
So then there's an effort by
the scientific community--
this famous conference called
Asimolar out in California,
where the whole community comes
together and kind of really
begins to work
through the ethics.
But their principal competitor,
Wally Gilbert at Harvard,
is forced, because of this
limit on genetic engineering
and the ability to
use genetic DNA--
he has to go to England,
where they're still
allowing that
research, and enlist
a whole group of
British scientists
to undertake his research.
But Swanson and Boyer get around
that by using synthetic DNA,
and they avoid the whole outcry.
So it's a very
interesting development.
It slowed down their
competitors pretty considerably.
Wally Gilbert was a great
talent to be up against--
I mean, a famous scientific
leader and researcher.
AUDIENCE: I didn't
do this reading
or know that much about the
genetic backgrounds at all,
but were the
pharmaceutical companies
at all their competitors?
Or are they very much so
focused on just chemicals?
AUDIENCE: I think
Boyer really came--
you saw that drawing
with the pseudo--
that's a bacterial plastic DNA.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Let's
go back to that, Sanam--
that original picture
of the two of them.
AUDIENCE: And you insert
your synthetic gene into it.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: There it is.
AUDIENCE: That--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --rectangle.
He basically came up with--
that wasn't in existence before,
and now it's used every day, in
almost every molecular biology
lab.
Yeah, so they don't think
that the pharmaceuticals
were onto this.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Yeah, looking at that,
you can try and guess which
one went to the Sloan School,
right?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I know.
They're wearing the same
kind of tie, though.
[LAUGHTER]
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Yeah, Boyer almost never
looked that good,
let me tell you.
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah.
[INAUDIBLE]
They look pretty similar.
I mean, also, Swanson
was chemistry every day
at MIT and then Sloan masters.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
AUDIENCE: He was like
pseudo-Sloan [INAUDIBLE]..
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: How about
another good question, Sanam?
SANAM: So something that some
of you who had read this kind of
raised, and I was curious
about as well, was--
so the initial years,
because it was so new
and because they
were doing something
that hadn't been
done before, there
was an increased amount of
risk-taking that was needed,
and they both really
staked their careers on it,
especially Swanson,
who ended up having
to check himself into hospital
when they had setback.
So I wonder if
there's, kind of, a way
to encourage more sustainable
risk-taking in people who
have the visions, like Swanson,
and people who are starting up
endeavors like this?
So there is a way to make it
that they are incentivized
to take these risks that
are necessary to further
their careers, but also,
maybe not to the point
that Swanson did.
AUDIENCE: At this
point, I've led
three innovation groups, where
I teach, sort of, people--
not just students, but people--
the engineering design cycle.
And I think one of
my big takeaways--
having taught students as
young as five years old
to individuals as old as
in their 50s, maybe 60s--
is that there really needs
to be a sense of safety
and security-- which was
something that was brought up,
I think, in the
Biederman reading--
which is, I think, one of
the reasons why there's
that, sort of, big paradigm
of founding a company out
of your dorm room.
Because there's something
that's implied there--
which is that you
have a place to live.
And that if you attend
an institution where
you have a dorm, you
also have access to food.
And you're also not super
concerned about getting
a paycheck.
And so, I think that
sense of security,
sort of both mentally, to sort
of take a step back and explore
your dreams, is really important
into the sense of stability.
Like, literally, access to
shelter, access to food,
access to health care
becomes really important.
So in those circumstances,
I feel like universities--
and not just, maybe, in
their undergraduate programs,
but maybe universities
generally-- provide
really interesting
opportunities to innovate
for these kinds of very
disruptive innovations,
because they do provide
this real holistic support
to an individual.
But that's still a theory
that I'm working under
and sort of hope to
continue exploring over,
maybe, a master's
thesis or a PhD.
But I think the other really
big point about mental health
is something that was also
addressed in the Biederman
reading, and it goes back
to that sense of safety
and security that, a lot
of times, individuals
who don't feel
comfortable in their,
sort of, organic or natural
ecosystem feel more stressed,
and thus, that prevents
them from being productive.
And so, I think about
that in the context
of the current
political situation
and the ways in which,
maybe, some people who
might be interested in
innovating or pursuing
innovative projects,
may not be able to do
so effectively because
of the ways in which
the political situation is
literally motivating stress
in their lives and is
preventing them from innovating.
So those are some thoughts.
I have a lot of them.
[INAUDIBLE] share those too.
AUDIENCE: I mean, on
the other side of that,
I think this-- the
aspect that having
stress, a necessary
stress, is important.
I think with the
Manhattan Project--
like there's no
safety and security
in thinking the Germans are
going to get the bomb first.
I mean, I couldn't think
of a better impetus
than this has to work, or I
don't have a house to live in,
or food to eat.
AUDIENCE: Well, actually,
that's actually not what
they had to deal with at all.
I mean, granted, they
would say, yeah, oh, we
don't have any lives, but--
so I kind of agree, but--
I mean, Oppenheimer did
mention in that paper
he went six months,
and he didn't even
realize he had a paycheck--
he hadn't received one.
And I saw that,
and I just thought
that was such privilege.
So the fact that someone
could have that sense of, OK,
well if this--
ignoring the implications
of, obviously,
failing on this project, outside
of the Manhattan Project,
any other technological
pursuit, I
think that definitely
helps someone
think more creatively
when you think about, oh,
how am I going to
pay for my car?
Or how am I going
to get to work?
Or whatever.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: So one
of the important rules,
I think here, is
that the group needs
to be on a protected island.
And the point you're
adding, Steph, I think,
is a significant one.
It needs to feel secure
in itself, right?
People have to be
comfortable in this group
to be willing to be creative
together and contribute
to each other.
I think that's an
important perception here
that probably applies to
a lot of these groups.
But--
AUDIENCE: --has to do
with that scarcity--
why having too
little means so much.
You don't have
your full bandwidth
if you're worried about
what you don't have
and what you need to work on.
So that's part of creativity.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Sanam, did this group
have that sense of security?
SANAM: I think from what I
read here, they definitely did.
I mean, a lot of them were--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
You don't see
in this picture the whole team,
but there's a whole team here.
SANAM: Yeah, there's a whole--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: It's very
collaborative with this duo.
SANAM: Yeah, and I think that
that was an interesting point
about--
I did kind of get
a sense that class
came into this in a way
that really benefited--
he went into
commercializing because he
had an altruistic vision,
which is interesting.
But he had that
ability to not have
to worry about making
money and things like that.
So I think that's a
very interesting point
that you all have raised.
And yeah, what you're
saying about how
people who feel like they
are actively under threat,
or they actively don't have
the basic necessities taken
care of, would not be
able to function, maybe,
in the way that make
those innovations that--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
They're on an island.
They're not starving
on the island.
SANAM: Yeah, exactly.
AUDIENCE: I think an
addendum that would be--
have any of you read
When Breath Becomes Air.
It's a book by Paul Kalanithi.
He was a neuroscientist,
who was a resident,
I believe, at Stanford.
[INAUDIBLE] neurosurgeon, who is
a medical resident at Stanford,
who's just about to complete
his neuroscience residency when
he was diagnosed
with brain cancer
and ended up passing
away, just shy
of completing his residency.
But there's a really
incredible portion
in his memoir, where
he talks about what
he had to do in order to be
able to achieve what he did,
which is, essentially, after
going to Stanford undergrad,
he spent a year,
essentially, being homeless,
living in an abandoned home
and taking classes at Stanford
while studying for the MCAT.
And I think there's a really--
the reason I recommend
everyone read this book
if they're interested
in, sort of,
becoming innovators, or
entrepreneurs, or people
who change the world
is that he elicits
a really great point
about not necessarily
just quote unquote male
privilege, but just privilege,
generally, because he
was able to, sort of,
opt out of being
alive and utilize
whatever money his
parents were sending him,
or whatever money he
had saved up, in order
to take these classes, in
order to study for the kind,
and then go on to do incredible
work in medical school
and then in residency.
And I feel like that's,
sort of, close as you get
and the clearest,
sort of, articulation
of the process of giving up your
whole life in order to pursue
this big dream that you have.
And so, Paul Kalanithi's
book, I think,
is a really, really great study,
not just of a great group,
but of a great individual,
and a person who's
sort of a risk taker, and
willing to give up their life
for their work, and
then ultimately,
obviously the conclusion
of it is quite beautiful,
and the narrative
arc is there, but--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: And these
folks are giving up medicine
to pursue the dream.
AUDIENCE: We're also looking
at the winners, though.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: We're only
looking at the winners, right?
AUDIENCE: I would
say that pretty much
every biotech entrepreneur ends
up with ulcers and high blood
pressure.
That's just-- they do.
And--
AUDIENCE: Or is it
every entrepreneur?
AUDIENCE: Probably.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
She only said biotech.
You're safe.
AUDIENCE: I know I'm more
familiar with the biotech side.
But I think that because these--
I think that's also
a characteristic
of the great group leaders--
that they're able to
take risks and get ulcers
so that the rest of their
team can feel the insulation
and as though they have the
opportunity for success,
resources, and security.
So I that's an aspect of this.
SANAM: Yeah, I agree.
There was a quote in the paper
that the scientist at Genentech
had no boss other than the
Swanson's nervous vigilance,
so that really carried
them through [INAUDIBLE]..
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: That's
a great line, Sanam.
That's good.
All right, let's
do Venter, Lily.
LILY: OK.
So I'm going over the Craig
Venter great group today.
A few of you have heard of him.
Most have not.
The leader of the great group,
of course, was Craig Venter.
And just going through some
of the Bennis and Biederman
necessities of great groupness,
or greatness in a group.
His mission from God was
to sequence and decode
the human genome-- so check,
we have a mission from God.
The island-- in this
particular case study,
while they were decoding
sequencing and decoding
the human genome, their
island was Celera,
which was a biotech that was--
it's complicated.
I'm going to try to keep
it as simple as possible
for the purposes of
this presentation.
Just know that Craig Venter
had many, many for-profits
and non-for-profits institutions
all running at the same time.
He now has now more
than he even used to,
so I'm just really going to talk
about Celera for the purposes
of this presentation.
And then the mainland-- he has
connections with the public.
There's a lot of publicity going
on at this time over the Human
Genome Project.
So that's sort of their highway
to the public, or the mainland.
And he has contacts,
still, at the NIH
and adversaries at
the NIH as well.
And they are,
indeed, the underdog.
Craig Venter's great
group defect from the NIH,
and they're up against
funding from the US government
and, actually,
international collaboration,
especially with the
British government.
And the enemy--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Sorry--
I think it's actually Watson
rather than Crick, right?
LILY: Oh.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Sorry.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
OK.
LILY: It is Watson.
I put the wrong one in there.
No, Francis Crick had
nothing to do with this.
It was Watson.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: And Watson
was heading the Genome Project
at NIH at the time.
LILY: Yeah.
Yeah.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: And
he drives Venter out.
LILY: And Venter and Watson
begin as a very powerful duo.
And Venter thinks
that the genome needs
to be sequenced in a
slightly different way,
and Watson is not OK with
that, because so much money
and so much effort
has been put into it--
the sort of outdated way.
And he completely
undermines Venter in front
of US Congress, et cetera.
And I'll get into
that a little more.
But yeah, basically,
the enemy is
anyone who pisses
off Venter, which
turns out to be quite a lot
of people over the years.
Venter-- Craig Venter, I
think, is one of the more--
one of the most
controversial scientists
in biotech in our time.
He's a very-- a little
bit of a hothead, and he--
people in science either
love him or hate him.
So a little bit of background.
His early life-- he's sort of--
he is reminiscent, for
me, of Thomas Edison.
He has some severe
learning issues,
almost flunks out of high
school, does not go to college.
He ends up a surfer bum
in Southern California
on Redondo Beach.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Now
I want to add one fact.
Not just one parent,
but both his parents
were Marines sergeants.
LILY: Yep, so--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: You can only
imagine what that does to you.
LILY: From this
militant household
and decides that
as soon as he is--
I think he's 17 when he
graduates from high school.
He decides, I'm
getting out of here.
I'm going to live in Redondo
Beach, in a surf shack,
and grow my hair out
long, and wear cutoffs.
So that was his, I think,
rebellion against his parents.
This is during the
time of Vietnam.
Venter realizes-- he comes
from a military family, first
of all, so I think he has
a somewhat a sense of duty.
But he also realizes that he's
probably going to get drafted,
and it's better for him if he
joins the Navy voluntarily.
He's actually an extremely
good competitive swimmer,
possibly Olympic quality.
So he joins the Navy,
thinking that he's
going to be on the swim team and
not actually see active duty.
And this turns out to be--
couldn't be farther
from the truth.
Vietnam ramps up, and
he is trained as an EMT
and deployed to Da Nang.
And he actually has two active
deployments in Vietnam--
sees some things that I think
changed his life forever.
In the interview,
he talks about how
he is the person he is because
of his time in Vietnam.
He survives and attends
community college
in California.
Transfers to UCSD, which is
University of California San
Diego, gets a BS and
then a PhD there.
I think he completed
his PhD in three years.
It was the fastest--
at that time, it was the fastest
biochem PhD in UCSD history.
He goes immediately to a
faculty position at Buffalo,
in New York.
Interesting transition
for him, yeah.
That's part of the interview.
He talks about how he's this
Californian with long hair
and then goes to goes to
Buffalo, where he begins
to make people angry, actually.
So he starts young on his path.
So he marries his PhD
student, Claire Fraser.
He's very clear that they get
married after she graduates,
so there's nothing
wrong with that at all.
And in 1984, he leaves
Buffalo, pretty much so
that she can start her--
prove herself as her own
scientist at the NIH.
And I think this is where
the great group really starts
to coalesce and starts to form.
Some sequence of events.
So while at the NIH,
Venter is traditionally
trained as a neuroscientist
working in receptors.
So is Claire Fraser.
They have separate
lab at the NIH,
but something that Venter
gets really interested in
is molecular biology.
He sees it as this field
that's going to explode,
is extremely important,
and is, basically,
our path to future medicine.
So he starts to try to get
funding to do molecular biology
experiments and get
into this field,
buy the machines necessary.
And he's totally
stonewalled at the NIH.
He's basically told, no,
you're a neuroscientist.
You can't work in this
other stovepipe at the NIH.
That's just not done.
It won't work.
So he becomes increasingly
and increasingly
frustrated with the
bureaucracy, basically.
And he says that
he looks around,
and he sees people who are
lifers at the NIH, who just
go through the motions
of being a scientist, who
couldn't really compete in
the academic, or the outside,
world.
So he does something
a little maverick.
He creates this-- he's
reading about and hearing
about the Human Genome
Project because it's
a big initiative at NIH.
And he decides,
well, if they're not
going to let me get into
molecular about biology
and sequencing the
human genome, then
I'm going to sneak
in by, basically,
sequencing a gene
involved in neurobiology.
So he does that, and he
invents this thing called EST.
And I'm not getting into it.
Honestly, it's such
an outdated thing
that I didn't even learn
about it during my studies.
And then Watson and
Venter have met.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: So Watson
is running the huge Human Genome
Project at NIH.
LILY: Right.
Venter comes up-- he has
the sequence of this gene.
He's made some pretty cool
breakthroughs and goes in
and meets with Watson.
And Watson gets excited
about it at first.
But then, Craig Venter goes
off and, kind of, procures
a machine, sort of
behind Watson's back--
it's what Watson thinks--
and makes Watson really mad.
So he totally
undermines and vilifies
Venter in front of
Congress and the US public,
because this is a huge--
this is a huge initiative.
People are talking about
it at the dinner table.
It's a big deal back in
the mid-1990s, I would say.
So Watson basically doesn't like
the way Craig's doing things.
So--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
So let me just
add one quick detail, Lily.
So there is an
issue here on what
gets patented on a project
like the human genome.
Can you patent
the genome, right?
So this whole
issue is coming up.
The general counsel
at NIH advises Venter
that, yes, we are going
to be able to patent
a lot of this emerging genetics
field, so let's protect--
he's a researcher for NIH.
So he's intramural
researcher at NIH.
Let's protect NIH by filing a
lot of the patents ourselves.
And the confrontation
with Congress
is where Watson attacks
Venter for patenting genome
technologies.
In other words,
it's not going to be
available to the
scientific world.
It's not going to be open based.
It's not going to
be in the commons,
even though Venter
had received--
had been told by the general
counsel's office at NIH
that that's what he had to do.
So that leads to this
explosion of anger by Venter.
LILY: Yeah, so--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Is
that a fair summary?
LILY: Definitely.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: OK.
LILY: Yeah, from Venter's
side of the story,
he says, I didn't necessarily
want to patent these genes.
The NIH advised me to.
It was their initiative.
And Watson used it as
a way to undermine me
in front of the American
public because he
didn't want me to use my
technology that I had come up
with.
So that's the-- sort
of the backstory.
Venter is insanely angry,
and he and his wife
defect from the
NIH and form Celera
with the help of
venture capitalists, who
later also anger Venter,
and that explodes.
And they take with them 12
men of their lab members
from the NIH.
So the team.
And I think that Craig
Venter really exemplifies
a great group leader in that he
seems able to identify talent
in others.
So they start out
with the 12 from NIH.
They have their
island of Celera.
And the team that
they start to form--
this is not including the
board of directors and such,
which also seemed to be
pretty amazing people.
But they recruit Hamilton--
actually I think--
Well, Hamilton Smith
comes onto the scene,
and he's their premier
molecular biologist.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: And
he's a Nobel Prize winner.
LILY: Did he?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yeah.
LILY: OK.
At--
AUDIENCE: Was that during
the time period or after?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Prior.
[INAUDIBLE]
LILY: Yeah.
Yeah.
So I don't think any of--
this is actually a question
I'm going to pose to the class
at the end of my presentation.
I don't think anyone
in this great group
has won a Nobel Prize, except--
like for this.
Previously Ham Smith.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
LILY: So Marshall Peterson
is this computer geek
because not only is Hamilton
Smith literally coming up
with the sequencing
technology to do this--
this is 30 billion
base pairs of DNA.
The most anyone has sequenced at
this point is like C. elegans,
or like a worm--
tiny, tiny genome.
So this is a huge deal.
They have to come up with
new sequencing technologies,
new ways to decode the
sequence, and new computing.
So they literally build
the third largest computer
on the planet, I think.
The DOE has a larger
computer, and there's someone
somewhere else in the world.
And they build this
massive computing facility
and then bring on Gene
Myers as this coder who's
coming up with the algorithms
to try to piece together
all these little pieces of
DNA and build a 30 billion
base sequence.
So in the meantime,
the public sector--
academia, the NIH-- are
becoming increasingly angry
with Craig Venter,
saying that he's
defecting to the
private sector, and he's
going after the human
genome for profit.
Craig is saying, I don't--
I'm not in this for profit.
I'm in this because
we need a human genome
so that we can promote human
molecular, biology-based
medicine.
In the meantime, he sequences
the drosophilid genome
and gives it--
publishes it in science.
Gives it--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Fruit fly.
LILY: Yeah, the fruit
fly genome, which people
have been trying to figure
out what genes in fruit fly
do for decades and
decades and decades.
And so, there's this
really cool part
in the interview where he talks
about this community of fruit
fly researchers, who, I think,
are kind of like the physics
community.
And they're pretty close-knit.
They have their
conferences, and they
try to get together, and
decode the fruit fly, which
they don't have the basis or
the knowledge to do that yet.
So they're doing it gene by
gene by gene over many years.
And Craig decodes the
fruit fly genome and says,
come to Celera.
I have all of the information
that you've been looking
for the past few decades.
And you can have it.
It's here.
So he says, maybe on the
order of 100 or so fruit fly
researchers come.
And they are just like
kids in a candy shop.
They stay up all
hours of the night
and making these
breakthroughs that they've
been looking for for decades.
So that's pretty
fun, pretty cool.
So fruit fly sequenced, NIH.
You would probably know
more about the interplay
between Francis Collins
and Venter, because that--
I don't-- I'm not-- it's
a little fuzzy for me.
I can never figure
out if they're
working together or
against each other,
but eventually, what
happens in 2001--
the NIH and the public--
like academia, so people
from different universities--
come together and
publish the human genome
in the journal Nature.
And two days later,
Celera announces the--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Same day.
LILY: Oh it is the same day?
It comes out in Science.
So this is--
AUDIENCE: Was that planned?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yeah.
LILY: Yeah.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
So there had to be--
I mean it's a
fascinating story, right?
And there's rich
MIT history, which
MIT was on the side of
NIH, just so you know.
So Venter, through
a research model
that was extremely
focused on getting
this project done, right?
Everything was to be
organized for the project.
NIH is on a research
model that could
be described as, let's
let 1,000 flowers bloom.
We'll have a lot of RL1
researchers out there.
Eventually, that will turn
into the Human Genome Project.
Someone made the analogy
to that research model
as, OK, if you put a whole
lot of monkeys into a room
and give them
typewriters, eventually
we'll get Shakespeare, right?
It's obviously
exaggeration here,
but Venter, with his
very focused research
project, and these computer
scientists, and Venter himself,
becomes a master
of the computers
that he's working on
building, and EST technology
is from that--
versus a much more decentralized
research operation.
So slowly NIH realized,
it's going to lose the race,
unless it gets its act together.
So they begin to
focus on getting rid
of the 1,000 flowers.
Let's get down to a small number
of focused research centers.
And it's a race,
really, between--
who's that Broad Institute head?
What's his name?
Oh, how can I forget?
Eric Lander.
Yeah, of course.
Sorry, excuse me.
So Eric's a mathematician.
He's not a life
scientist, right?
And he becomes the leader of the
Human Genome Project for NIH.
Collins is heading
it, but Eric is
the one who's carrying out
the computational parts of it,
right?
And they do it in cooperation
with this Department of Energy
supercomputer labs, because they
need their own supercomputing
capability.
Venter's built his.
NIH uses DOE.
So this race is ongoing.
The NIH crowd is
attacking Venter
constantly for, essentially,
trying to profit
from patenting the genome.
That's their
complaint-- that he's
going to take this critical
scientific advance,
critical to the
future of medicine,
and take it out of circulation
and access to science,
and patent it, and prevent
anybody from using it.
That's the case being
made against him.
It's pretty far, in reality,
from what the truth is,
but that's the case being made.
And Eric and the NIH
team are gradually--
they are using some of
Venter's technology.
They're originating,
certainly, many of their own.
They're within range.
So at that point,
a negotiated truce
is arranged so that nobody
gets embarrassed here, right?
And the real worry was that
NIH would lose the race, right?
So eventually, Venter is
prevailed on to declare a tie,
and each side will
publish, in the two
major scientific publications,
their version of the genome.
And that's, in
fact, what occurs.
It's-- Go ahead.
LILY: Two points I want to make.
One is that in this
interview, Venter
says that he finds out that
Francis Collins, the head
of the NIH, has
budgeted less than half
of what it's going to
take at their current rate
to complete the human genome.
So in his mind, Collins
has no intention
of really completing it.
And they can't-- as
the way things stood.
The other point I wanted
to make is that the NIH--
Venter's enemies and
adversaries keep bombarding him
in the public by
saying he's going
to profit off the human genome.
And there is a little--
there's actually
a lot of friction between Venter
and his venture capitalists,
because he wants to publish.
Publish, publish,
publish the findings
that they're making so that
other people can utilize them.
And the venture capitalists
keep saying, no, we
don't want-- you can't do that.
You can't do that.
It's private.
We want to patent, et cetera.
So there's that
friction going on.
So yes, eventually
published at the same time.
Celera actually-- Venter is--
both quits and is fired from
Celera at the same time.
And--
AUDIENCE: Which one came first?
LILY: In Venter's mind, he
was about to quit anyway,
but yeah, he was basically asked
to leave on a Monday morning.
AUDIENCE: He's truly the
Steve Jobs of biology.
LILY: Yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, there are a
lot of parallels.
AUDIENCE: Even the hippie phase.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: But
Martine, he's different, right?
He creates this group,
originally, at his NIH lab.
It's basically still
with him, right?
LILY: Yeah, they
want to follow him.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
This is not Jobs's abrasiveness,
right, and screaming.
This is somebody who is really--
he's a pretty
charismatic figure.
I've spent a little
time with him.
And he is able to keep an
absolutely remarkable team
together for a remarkably
long period of time.
So it's a different personal
atmosphere, a different kind
of leadership style.
But remember what it
must have been like.
I mean, he comes back
from the Vietnam War
full of Navy and Marine
Corps tattoos, right?
He's a veteran of this
ghastly war, and he's been--
he's seen some of
the worst outcomes,
running a whole hospital
wing, virtually on his own,
in Da Nang, and sees
death and loss of life,
and trying to save
life, firsthand,
in a very personal kind of way.
He's completely different than
the kind of culture of NIH.
He's up from a working
class, military family,
and it's just a different world
that he's been exposed to.
And he doesn't get
along with this kind
of established liberal
community of scientists at NIH.
So that's part of what's going
on here, I think, really.
LILY: Yeah, I think what's--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: He's just
a really different character.
LILY: What's always
pushing him at the NIH is
and throughout the
Human Genome Project is,
decode the human genome so
we don't see the situation,
or the things that he saw
in the hospital at Da Nang.
He doesn't-- he thinks
that modern medicine should
eradicate those
sorts of injuries.
His vision is synthetic biology.
Regrow.
Regrow everything synthetically.
Regrow human limbs.
He's very forward
thinking as far
as the medical uses
of knowing genetics.
AUDIENCE: I had this question.
So what exactly were they
trying to patent on either side
that we see?
LILY: Lots of things.
So I think that one worry
was that his invention--
Craig's method of EST
would be patented itself.
And it's an extremely-- it
was for a-- well some areas
of biology still use it.
Not my particular field, but
a lot of areas of biology
still use it.
And if it were patented, they
wouldn't be able to, obviously.
So it's widely applicable.
It's technique.
And there was worry that
he would try to patent EST,
or there might have--
I think there was a
patent in, and the NIH
pulled it, or
something like that,
with so much negative press.
There were a couple of other
things up for patent, maybe,
but I don't know the specifics.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Why don't
we get in some questions.
LILY: Yeah, OK.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Do
you have any more slides?
LILY: But I wanted
to let you know--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Oh.
Oh yes.
OK.
LILY: What does he do?
So Celera--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: This
is what he's doing now.
LILY: Celera goes boom
with the dot come bubble.
It's worth $15 billion, and
the stock goes from 500 bucks
to $6.
At that point, Craig
had already left.
One of the reasons that the
stock dropped so drastically
was because people found
out that Craig left.
So now-- well not now,
but then, he decides,
well I'm going to
do my own science,
and I'm going to sequence
the entire ocean.
I'm done with the human genome.
Now I'm going to
go to the ocean.
So he gets on this 100 foot
yacht-- the Sorcerer II.
And a couple of people--
I taught with a woman
who's a professor at USC,
who was on some of the
Sorcerer legs of the journey.
And then her husband,
John Heidelberg
is on-- he was on my
thesis committees,
so he's the third
author on this paper.
And they have lots of fun
Craig stories as well.
And one of the--
I think one of the themes
throughout the great groups
is that, there are
a lot of partiers.
If they're not doing
really crazy, good science,
they're partying.
So they dock, and they just
have the big huge party.
So then he finishes
sailing around the world
a couple of times and sequencing
all the bacteria in the ocean
and sets up the JCVI, which
is located in La Jolla,
right next to his
alma mater, UCSD.
So that's a picture of
Craig from a few years ago.
So to conclude, a few
choice quotes from Craig.
"I've gotten some
pretty nice awards.
And I'm having trouble finding
places to put them all."
And then one that's more
pertinent to this class
is, "The environment has fallen
to the wayside in politics."
And lastly-- oh, I wanted
to go over Venter's thoughts
on innovation, but that's not--
we're getting close on time,
so that's not really necessary.
These are better.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: How
about some questions?
LILY: OK, so show of--
I wanted to see, in the
class, by a show of hands.
Who thinks that Venter, or
maybe a couple of people
within his group--
I mean, they decoded the
human genome, which was--
just the amount of new
technologies that they came up
with, both in computing
and molecular biology,
in order to do that
are astounding.
So who in here would say he
should be a Nobel Prize winner?
Or people in his group?
AUDIENCE: I'm sure
there's got to be
some other equivalent,
biology-centered award, right?
AUDIENCE: I mean, he could just
make his own award and then.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
LILY: Well, he's got a
lot of them [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: I mean,
but [INAUDIBLE]
give out your own award.
AUDIENCE: If there's a
Watson and Crick award,
and he wins it, imagine how
hilarious that would be.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
That won't happen.
AUDIENCE: --it was self-critical
and then was like--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Watson.
AUDIENCE: Oh, Watson.
LILY: Yeah, sorry.
AUDIENCE: When they started,
a lot of their stuff
was based off of
Schrodinger's What is Life?
That's how they come up with the
DNA, because it was mentioned.
And they were seen as
nobodys up to that point.
It's really interesting.
AUDIENCE: Lily, can
I ask a really simple
semantic question?
Why do they call it
decoding, and not encoding,
the human genome?
LILY: I think it would be
called decoding because--
AUDIENCE: You're
only reading it.
LILY: What this looks like
when you actually read
the bases is fluorescent dye.
So you have to read--
you have to decode the
fluorescent signature in order
to get the base pairs.
AUDIENCE: So it's not about--
it's about, more so, evaluating
the results than it is about,
sort of, expressing the result?
LILY: Yeah.
Yeah, I would [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: They also did
something cool that's
you inject DNA into
like a bacteria
and it changed the way it was.
[INAUDIBLE] changed
the lifeform.
I was--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: One thing
about this effort here--
you have to get a sense
for how transformational
this seemed in the 1990s,
because it was really
quite amazing.
But this was one of the
great scientific competitions
of all time, right?
This incredible race to do the--
to decode the genome.
And this is being--
this a major news story, right?
And Francis Collins has
a Harley motorcycle,
and sings in a
blues band, and he
has his own fast-- he still
rides his motorcycle into work
at NIH.
Venter is a yachtsman, who
buys these wild, incredibly
dangerous sailboats and loves
that kind of wild adventure
of being in a tempestuous
sea, close to the wind,
and near capsize danger,
with these monster sailboats.
So both of them have their,
kind of, wild side here.
There's no question about it.
But this competition captures
the public imagination.
And it's a very important
race, because the race
forces incredible
speed in the project.
So what had probably
been originally viewed
as a 40-year project
that gets knocked down
to well less than a
decade by the time
these characters kind
of complete the race
and agree to a truce by
publishing on the same day.
And in turn, I was
working in the Senate
while this is all going on.
And the public was
getting a sense, gee,
we really are
getting fairly close
to some absolutely
fundamental answers, here.
And when two US senators--
Senator Specter
and Senator Harkin
from Pennsylvania and
Iowa, respectively--
were chair and ranking on the
appropriations subcommittee
that handles NIH.
They actually-- there's was--
in the Clinton years-- because
of the IT revolution is
creating a lot of
extra tax revenue--
were balancing the budget.
So there's revenue, on
one of those rare moments,
there's revenue in the federal
government Specter and Harkin
go down and take the revenue.
And that's what doubles NIH.
And nobody says they're wrong
because of the excitement
that this race to get to
the genome has created
and what it's scientific
possibilities are.
So sure, there's a
whole political effort
to radically
increase NIH funding,
but the enabler here is
the public excitement
around the genome race and
what its possibilities might
be to accomplish.
So this has enduring,
kind of, lasting effects
that spill over in
many kind of ways
into the life science arena.
Next question.
How about-- you want to
pose a couple of questions,
and then we'll wrap things up.
LILY: Yeah, one of the things
I was thinking about while
reading this and the other
readings in the class
is that Venter seems to
form and dissolve and reform
multiple great groups
throughout his lifetime--
from the 80s to present day.
And in thinking
about other great--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
But Lily, he's only
changing the formal structure.
The team really follows him
from one organizational model
to another--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: That's true.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: In many way.
LILY: So do we think
that most great group
leaders have a great--
one great group, and
that's their opus.
They don't go on and--
they have one mission.
AUDIENCE: When you say group,
do you mean a following?
Or a team?
LILY: One team.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
mean, I would disagree.
Well just a counterexample
I'll give is Apple.
Because there is the Mac
team-- those are very unique.
So I'll take certain products.
Or if it's a one particular
problem, you have a group.
And them you can choose
to decay the group after.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yeah, Apple
is remarkable for its ability
to go from one major technology
launch to another in sequence.
It's really--
AUDIENCE: It's hard, yeah.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: --very
hard and very difficult.
And interestingly, it hasn't
happened since Jobs died.
AUDIENCE: That we know of.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
That we know of, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Who else
is a [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: I feel
like they'd release
some information
about that, seeing
as how the hype around Apple's
kind of starting to die down.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
There's a model in history.
I mean, how does a
big company innovate?
It's a terribly
difficult problem, right?
They're the suits.
They're the bureaucracy.
Lockheed is kind of noted
as the experimenter here.
They set up something
called the Skunk Works
as a completely side,
separate organization
on a protected
island, with a bridge
back to the Lockheed management.
And they do remarkable advances
in aeronautics and aerospace.
So they do the U-2.
They do the SR-71 Blackbird,
which many people to this day
think is the most
remarkable plane ever built.
But then a whole sequence
of other aircraft.
And they do stealth, right?
They're the implementers of a
lot of the stealth technology.
So that's an example
of how a corporation is
able to create an
entity that can
move through a series of great
groups and keep innovating.
That's kind of held up as
a kind of iconic model.
So it is possible.
So when your-- the small
companies that you all set up
become major corporations,
read about Skunk Works,
because that'll be your
clue to continued survival.
AUDIENCE: Ray
Stata did something
interesting like that, where his
company, they wouldn't fund--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: That's
Analog Devices, just up
the street.
AUDIENCE: They wouldn't
fund [INAUDIBLE]
to digital technologies.
And so what he had to
do is, he personally
putting in his own money
to make a new company
that the old company
could not buy back.
So he had to get
over it that way.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
That's Interesting.
Lily, how about a
closing thought for us
about this amazing crowd?
LILY: Let's see.
I think that Craig is right when
he says you have to take risks.
You have to take
risks or else you're
not going to do anything
worth writing about.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: And
that's a great way to close.